on a mission once again
weeks after the Chinese Coast Guard used
water cannon against these two wooden
boats they're back with supplies for
Filipino troops sailing towards the
second Thomas Shoal in the south of
China Sea Al Jazeera was one of a number
of selected media outlets on board the
Philippine Coast Guard vessel escorting
the Navy chartered Supply boats
before setting sail we were warned the
Chinese will almost certainly stand in
our way
we always encountered dangerous
maneuvers shadowing activities
true enough as we got closer to the BRP
Sierra Madre the old warship Manila
deliberately grounded to stake its claim
on the second Thomas show the Chinese
Coast Guard issued one radio challenge
after another I love you
immediately
the warnings were followed by an hour's
long Chase with Chinese vessels
outnumbering the Filipinos
and we are being surrounded by Chinese
vessels now the Chinese Coast Guard
vessel has been shadowing us for a while
now at one point sailing as close as six
meters to this vessel according to the
Philippine Coast Guard crew on board
with us
[Music]
moments later our camera captured this
moment when one of the Chinese Coast
Guard ships deliberately closed in on us
so close we feared its bow would Ram our
vessels Hull the supply ships slipped
through but we were boxed in
but it doesn't mean nah they are
allowing the supply vessels in the first
place we don't even have to ask for
their permission
the second Thomas Shoal is about 140
nautical miles or about 200 kilometers
from our port of departure in Palawan
the Philippines westernmost Province but
China claims sovereignty over nearly the
entire south of China Sea and while
Beijing says is committed to Peaceful
dialogue at the recently concluded asean
Summit in Jakarta Philippine president
Ferdinand Marcos Jr said actions speak
louder than words we cannot emphasize
enough that actions not words should be
the ultimate measure of our commitment
to securing peace and stability in the
South China Sea
Marcus has joined foreign allies to
press for freedom of navigation a U.S
Navy aircraft was hovering above as
Philippine and Chinese forces were in a
standoff even as talks are still
underway for joint Patrols
Barn below Al Jazeera in the south of
China Sea
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera